Brett how much do you know about construction?
I know a little bit about construction, son
What do you know/
I mean, I built the basics, you know? Shop class
we are building flats, son
a set
you know how they have walls, and you can turn those walls and you can change those walls up
we're building those, son
I love how you have the dimensions written down
like, 10 foot high and 8 foot wide
oh, I gotta get gas, by the way
I only put 91 in this
you got no gas?
the gas gauge doesn't work
ooooooooh
what you got in there?
dude, Metallica black album
(Enter Sandman - Metallica)
we need to look at, um, sort of plywood they have
first
here we go, this kind of s hit
this one's all warped, dude
is it?
yeah, dude
they're all gonna be warped
what kind of a fucking comment is that?
i mean, no the top one's gonna be more warped
listen, just help me with these
nick, you wanna hold this?
oh, here's a warped one
some people uhhhh
instead of having their kids, to adopt them
it gives more meaning outta life
when you
are you talking shit about my kids?
noooo noooo noo noo haha
sometimes, its like, a gem to go to an orphanage
im saying, warped boards son
sometimes the warped children are better...
uh... cut this, man
sometimes the warped boards are the best
(laughter)
step 1 complete: we've got the
4 by 8 birch boards
aaand now we're gonna go get the framing
anytime you're buying boards, son, you always wanna check it out
it's all warped and shit
here, this one. This is a good one
oh, yeah, that's a good one alright
this one is fucking legit, dude, look at this one
aw man, that's good
thats real nice
hey, is that one of those adopted sons?
it seems that most people
are unclear
on how
a ratchet strap works
every other time i give ratchet straps
to somebody
and they bring them back to me
they're bundled up like this
incorrectly
this is an avoidable problem, people
so, i'm gonna do a quick tutorial after i unbind this one
and we're gonna learn how to solve this
Dude, I just found a cookie dude
freakin cookie in my jacket, son
(muffled) it was in my jacket
(laughter)
this fucking guy
it is such a pain in the ass to get undone because
as you unbind it it becomes less and less
slack to work with
it becomes more and more difficult to actually unbind
i dont understand
how the world doesn't know how to DRIVE FUCKING STICKSHIFTS
or... ratchet ratchet straps
this is basic shit, people
you wanna try this?
im gonna try off a little bit
i want you to supervise
try a piece...
lieutenant dan..
ice cream
lieutenant dan!
just never loan a ratchet strap
'cause if you know how to ratchet
you already have your own, and if you don't you're gonna fuck it up
so just never loan a ratchet, thats the bottom line
Oh my god, there's another after that!?
you gotta be kidding me
im gonna go grab a water
dude
(exhales)
this is unbelievable
who did this?!
we're gonna fucking do this
for the purpose of the tutorial
almost... there...
ass
yeah
have you seen any evidence?
of a another one?
do you think they wouldn't be getting in the food
they come out every night
and run around
thats what rats do, that's why rats are the lowest
animals
nah, dude, worms are great
worms are lifegivers
blue bellied lizards are just reptiles
man
they didn't do anything
here's how you do
a ratchet strap
you have your basic ratchet
like that
it closes
this way
(clicking noises)
you take the other end
you bring it underneath
like that
kay, you see that?
underneath the metal thing and then you go through the middle
right there
underneath and through
the middle
so that
while you're ratcheting, this end
is sticking
out
if this end is getting wrapped up underneath
what you're ratcheting
you did it wrong
this end should be sticking out
so that when you ratchet it bundles here
but doesn't bundle your pulley
that way you can get it undone without having to do what i just did
for 25 minutes in a home depot parking lot
brett, thank you for the water
i apologize for swearing in your general direciton
while i was
undoing the strap
it was just a little frustrating
its ok
you know
sometimes you see somebody in a troubling spot and they look like they want a cookie
you just wanna do your best to help out
fufill that
(Music) thats right
(music)
first step is to put the wall faces out and then see how we need to set up the frame
then once you put all the pieces in place for the frame
you mark them with letters
so you know where they go
and then you just put it all together
pretty simple
(nailgun noises)
just set this one here
we did it before trump
we did it son
nice wall
thanks man
we're making the final touches
although this is the protoype
and i think one thing we learned
from the prototype
is that we wanna be able to store these as effectively as possible
so instead of nailing
these into the wall
next time, I'm
just gonna use metal hooks
and it'll just drop right in
we can do an 8 by 8 foot wall
without labour
or anything, just some
materials, for about 140 USD
not super
cheap
but, in the grand scheme of thing
if it allows us to shoot in here more
it saves us location money
frickin' destroy them, shoot shit at 'em
paint all over them
dirty them up, whatever
you want to do to them
you can do because they're just fake walls
you don't have to worry about ruing your nice, real walls
pretty sweet